going back to how does the film and
television industry work so let's
suppose someone has a reputable agent
they've checked them out and they know
that they're in good standing there's no
grievances or complaints and then
they've had this agent submit on behalf
of dental studio what's the process like
what should they expect what's the
timeframe
what if it's optioned what what happen
that's a lot of questions at one time
certainly it does take time there are
more than a thousand pieces of materials
submitted every month to the studios
you know maybe slightly less to larger
production companies but it's a lot of
material
somebody's got to read it has to go up a
chain of command so it does take a
little while I would say reasonable time
they usually get things done you know
read it and we'll be able to tell you in
four to six weeks roughly that's what it
used to be when I was working at the
studios it could be maybe slightly
longer now although a lot of lot of
times it's now everything is now on
computer so you could just read it at
your at your leisure you don't have to
wait for things to be mailed and that
kind of stuff but I I do think that a
lot of times it also depends on who else
is submitting material there may be a
more important agent or there may be an
agent who has a script that has some
famous actor or director attached to it
they are going to get preference so
sometimes the scripts get put that push
down a little lower a little lower a
little lower so you do have to watch out
for that and I do think that it's
important that people understand that
for first-timers it's you're going to be
there up towards the bottom and so it
probably would be longer so I would say
you know for to say four to six weeks
and if you don't hear anything what you
do is you just email or call your your
your agent and just ask them about it
also find out from them if they've heard
anything because usually they don't just
submit it to one place they usually try
to submit it to a few places because
they want to get a consensus of what of
what engine
what the producers and the studio people
are looking for well let's suppose
somebody says we like it it's a go what
happens what are some of the
possibilities well first of all I don't
think they're going to say it right away
but they will probably say we are
interested in this can you tell us more
and one of the other questions that is
going to ask what else do you have
because they want to know is just this
person if they like your writing
coloring that what else do they have
and what genre is it is this somebody
that a writer that we want to kind of
like maybe get a jump on their other
material they're always thinking ahead
because they don't want to just put all
their eggs in one basket they want to
know that there's somebody that's got
free-flowing talent that's going to
continue to build a relationship on and
that's why agents are always going to
ask that of you before they take you on
as a client what else do you have what
else you have
and that because the studio and the
producers always ask whatever what else
this guy have you know they want to know
is this does this writer have more
material because they would like to look
at more material
you